encuentra el octavo término de la
siguiente sucesión 1440 mil 716 mil 848
etcétera cuyos términos se forman
multiplicando los correspondientes
términos de dos sucesiones aritméticas y
bueno lo primero que vamos a hacer es
pensar en estas asociaciones aritméticas
que nos dice esta segunda oración
queremos dos sucesiones aritméticas que
están multiplicando en sus
correspondientes términos y esas
sucesiones aritméticas me dan la
sucesión que tengo aquí arriba así que
vamos a suponer que la primera solución
aritmética es ésta
empezamos en am después pues como es una
sucesión aritmética le sumamos una razón
entonces a am le agregamos una razón
porque es una asociación aritmética y
después para llegar al siguiente término
hay que volverle a agregar otra razón
entonces me quedaría a más 12 m y
después a más 13 m a más 4 m y así hasta
llegar al término 8 que por cierto sería
muy bueno sacarlo de una vez porque
precisamente eso es lo que nos pregunta
este problema la multiplicación del
octavo término de mis dos sesiones
aritméticas así que bueno
que el segundo término le sumamos una m
al tercer término le sumamos 12 m
entonces al octavo término le vamos a
sumar solamente 7 m bueno esta es mi
primera sucesión aritmética y ahora me
voy a fijar en segunda sugestión
aritmética porque son 2 y mi segunda
sucesión aritmética voy a suponer que
empieza en ver y después le sumamos una
razón no forzosamente tiene que ser la
misma por eso le voy a poner n b
n después vemos 12 nm y así no seguimos
hasta llegar al octavo término de esta
sucesión aritmética que por cierto es el
término b 7 n esto lo sabemos porque
siempre aumentamos una n menos una razón
menos del término que tenemos y bueno ya
aquí tenemos a mis dos sucesiones
aritméticas y qué voy a hacer con ellas
multiplicar las porque cuando yo
multiplico la primera sucesión
aritmética con la segunda sucesión
aritmética obtengo la sucesión que tengo
aquí arriba es decir 1440 etcétera y
bueno de hecho esto nos va a servir
porque si yo multiplico el primer
término de la primera sucesión por el
primer término de la segunda asociación
esto ya me dice que tiene que ser 1440
esto es justo lo que me está diciendo
problema recuerda que lo que dice el
problema es que esta sucesión de que
arriba sale de multiplicar mis dos
sucesiones aritméticas
y bueno si yo me tomo mi segundo término
de esta sucesión y multiplicó por el
segundo término de la otra sucesión esto
me tiene que dar el segundo término de
esta sucesión que es mil 716 esto me
tiene que dar mil 716 y también me dan
en el tercer término entonces vamos a
aprovecharlo y vamos a apuntar lo por
acá si yo multiplico a 12m que es el
tercer término de mi primera sucesión
aritmética y esto lo multiplicó por b
más 12 n que es el tercer término de mi
segunda sucesión aritmética esto me
tiene que dar igual a 1848 a esto que
está aquí a 1848 y bueno vamos a apuntar
también qué es lo que queremos lo que
queremos es la multiplicación del octavo
término de mi primera sucesión
aritmética por el octavo término de mi
segunda sucesión aritmética es decir a
más 7 m que multiplica a su vez ab7 n
ave más 7 n
esto es lo que yo quiero saber bueno ya
que tengo toda esta información lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta es
que abordé es igual a 1440 esto va a ser
importantísimo y pues vamos a ver qué es
lo que queremos yo lo que quiero es
encontrar este octavo término y este
octavo término se le debe multiplicar a
más 7 m
por de más 7 n cuánto es esto vamos a
hacer la multiplicación porque esta es
una multiplicación algebraica entonces
vamos a multiplicar este por este que me
queda por ver después este por este y me
queda 7 que multiplica que multiplica a
n y después éste por este me queda 7 de
m 7 bm y por último me queda 49 mn
déjame mover un poco la pantalla para
acá en queda 49 m n muy bien y entonces
esto es justo lo que yo quiero así que
déjame encerrarlo en un cuadrado porque
esto es tras lo que voy muy bien ahora
lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que
al menos ya sabemos algo por 10.440 esta
información como nos va a ser útil y por
lo tanto en lugar de poner aquí a por
ver voy a poner mil 4
40 y al menos tengo una cantidad de este
octavo término que es el que yo quiero
entonces ya al menos dimos un pequeño
paso ahora vamos a usar también la
información que nos dan de los otros dos
términos
tengo que am acm por vez más n esto es
igual a mil 716 y cuánto es esto
aprobé está por ver más apuren es a por
en más de por n más m por él en más m
por ende esto es igual a mil 716 lo
único que hice fue la multiplicación
algebraica pero ya sé cuánto vale a de
ave vale 1440 entonces yo aquí tengo que
haber vale 1440 y lo quiero pasar del
otro lado entonces voy a restar de ambos
lados de esta igualdad 1440 menos 1440
menos 1440 y de este lado pues estos dos
se van se cancelan mientras que me queda
a n más bm más nn y esto va a ser igual
a mil 716 menos 1440 y que me queda de
esto 6 -0 es esto es 64 para 11
esto es ponerlo 64 para 11 7 y esto se
convierte en 6 entonces me queda 7 y
después de 6 menos 4 que es 2 y uno
menos uno es cero es decir que además bm
más mn esto es igual a 276 ya usted la
información de mis primeros términos ya
usted la información de mis segundos
términos pues vamos a ver qué es lo que
me dicen mis terceros términos y para
esto voy a hacer lo mismo la
multiplicación algebraica de quien de
estos dos y que me queda aporte más dos
veces a n dos veces a n más dos veces bm
más dos veces bm estos dos están aquí
dos veces bm y por último más 4 mn4 mn y
bueno yo sé que esto tiene que ser igual
a 1848 porque es lo que me dice el
problema pero de igual manera aquí ya
tengo el valor de ave que es 1440
entonces vamos a usarlo y restamos de
ambos lados de la ecuación 1440 menos
mil 440 mil 2.440 y ya no me cabe le voy
a poner por acá
total estos dos se van y me quedan dos a
n 2b m 4 men-2a n lo voy a poner por
trabajo para que se vean todo muy claro
por aquí está muy bien 2 a n 2b m más
4mn esto tiene que ser igual a quien
bueno en 1848 - 1440 en lo cual es a 408
éstos lo mismo que 408 perfecto y si te
das cuenta aquí tengo una ecuación o una
igualdad que todas es divisible entre 2
entonces vamos a sacar la mitad si yo le
sacó mitad me queda a n n más vehemente
más dos nn más 2 mn esto es igual a la
mitad de 408 que es 204 esto es igual a
204 y perfecto ya con esto estoy
utilizando también mi tercera
información que me dan es decir la
información que me dan de la
multiplicación de ministrers ceros
términos pero ahora vamos a utilizar un
poco más lógica fíjate bien aquí tengo a
n más bm más m n y aquí lo que quiero es
nueve veces mn y entonces para no
complicarme la vida lo que voy a hacer
es que como aquí tengo séptima y aquí
tengo séptima a estos dos voy a tomar de
aquí y este 49 lo voy a tomar de acá así
que déjame ponerlo aquí si yo de esta
ecuación que tengo aquí y de esta
ecuación que tengo aquí
lo que hago es despejar ya sé vamos a
eliminar todo lo que se pueda voy a
restar esta ecuación de esta otra y me
va a quedar menos a ene - bm menos m n
esto es igual a menos 276 lo que estoy
haciendo restando a la segunda ecuación
le voy a restar la primera ecuación y
por lo tanto esto me va a servir
bastante porque con el método de suma y
resta estos dos se van estos dos se van
aquí solamente me queda un nn y yo sé
que m n es exactamente lo mismo que 204
menos 276 lo cual es menos 72 m nm es
igual a menos 72 y ya lo puedo poner
aquí estos 49 que multiplica a mn pero
mn vale menos 72 ahí vamos pasito a
pasito elián menos es lo que vale
mn
y ya con esto vamos a seguir utilizando
la información mn vale menos 72 menos 72
y entonces para el de otro lado va a
pasar como más 72 o dicho de otra manera
vamos a sumar 72 de ambos lados de la
ecuación y me queda que a n más bm n bm
es igual a quien pues estos dos se van y
me queda 276 más 72 lo cual es 87 7 14
llevamos 11 y 2 son 3 n más bm es lo
mismo que 348 perfecto y esto me va a
servir bastante porque yo aquí tengo a
james me parece un poquito yo aquí tengo
7 veces
n 7 veces bm esto es lo mismo toda esta
expresión que tengo arriba es
exactamente equivalente a poner 1440 que
está por ben y estos dos voy a
factorizar un 7 lo voy a escribir como 7
que multiplica a en bn déjame ponerlo
así de estos dos te voy a escribir como
7 que multiplica
bm pero ya sé cuánto vale a en el bm
bm vale 348 entonces me quedan 7 que
multiplica a 348 muy bien ya esto le voy
a agregar 49 que multiplica a menos 72
49 mn pero mn vale 72 negativo y
entonces me queda más 49 que multiplica
a menos 72 y ya tengo lo que vale por
fin este término octavo de mi sucesión
rara que tenía en un principio lo que
tengo que hacer es estas cuentas que
tengo por aquí perfecto ya logré tener
una expresión completamente numérica así
que vamos a hacer las cuentitas así que
me queda cuánto es 348 por 7 7 por 8 son
56 y llevamos 5 7 por 4 28 más 5 son 33
y llevamos 3 y entonces me quedan 7 por
3 21 7 por 3 21 más 3 son 24 y entonces
esto de aquí vale 2436 entonces me queda
1440 más dos mil 436 está bien vamos a
verificar los siete por 856 llevamos 56
y sí sí sí
entonces vamos a sumar estos dos una vez
me queda 6 7 8 y 3 es decir que la suma
de estos dos me da 3 mil 876 estos dos
valen 3 mil 876 así que déjenme ponerlo
por acá y ahora lo que hay que hacer es
49 x menos 72 49 x 72 es 2 x 9 18
llevamos 12 por 48 más 19 pongo un 0 7
por 9 63 y llevamos 67 por 428 más 6 es
lo mismo que 34 34 perfecto y ahora
vamos a sumar 82 llegamos 15 y 33 528
entonces esto hay que quitarle 35 28 y
que me va a quedar vamos a bajar un poco
la pantalla y dice 8 para 16 es 8 y esto
se convierte en 68 para 16 es 8 y
entonces me queda 6 menos 248 menos 5
que es 3 y estos dos se van por fin
logramos el octavo término de esta
sucesión que era una sucesión de
multiplicar dos sucesiones aritméticas
es 348 perfecto ya quedó resuelto este
problema